se han lanzado hoy por lo menos 10
misiles desde el sur de líbano hacia el
norte de israel ha sido informado el
ejército israelí y poco tiempo después
reivindicó los lanzamientos la milicia
chiita libanesa hezbollah estos misiles
aparentemente no han herido a nadie lo
que si todos los habitantes de la
galilea del norte han sido urgidos a
permanecer en los refugios antiaéreos de
los misiles 5 han sido interceptados por
el sistema de defensa antimisiles cúpula
de hierro y en estos momentos el primer
ministro naftalí bennett está reunido
con el ministro de defensa benny gantz y
el jefe del estado mayor aviv kochavi
para calibrar qué pasos a seguir
mientras tanto ejército el ejército
israelí está devolviendo el golpe con
fuego de artillería sobre las lanzaderas
de misiles de esta región del sur de
líbano los misiles han caído hoy en una
zona llamada ardoz de como decimos el
norte de la galilea este lugar ha sido
testigo de otros enfrentamientos entre
hezbollah
y recordemos que la milicia chiita y
este país han lidiado dos guerras
abiertas en los últimos tiempos por eso
el hecho de que se sepa ahora que los
misiles lanzados han sido acción de
hezbollah complica las cosas y hace que
esa frontera vulnerable desde el punto
de vista israelí preocupe todavía más se
está en situación de alerta y a la
espera